on Prime crime it's gonna be a missing
person Lauren Giddings investigators
desperate search for answers you used to
watch her come in and out of her
apartment didn't you you know
neither live leads to the interrogation
of a suspect that just won't break one
word answers dazed confused how can you
remember a statute and you can't
remember what you did two days ago
thank you
[Music]
hi there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases as many of
you know we focus heavily on police
interrogations and suspects well they
act in all kinds of ways but the person
you're about to see being interviewed he
just may be different than all the rest
June 30th 2011 it's going to be a
missing person
the missing person is Lauren Giddings
down in Macon Georgia police are alerted
to a disturbing situation we had
received a call friends and family
neighbors they were worried that they
hadn't seen her in the last few days
Lauren Giddings was from Maryland and
went to college and then law school she
had graduated in May and began studying
for the bar she was a person who had
lots of friends she was very much well
liked she was a runner she was an
excellent student the morning that we
went out there we were able to gain
access to her apartment her car was
there her keys were there the palm of
her pocketbook was there her cell phone
was there her laptop was there you were
in the graduating class with Lauren
right
Giddings and you knew her right yeah and
y'all live in the same apartment complex
she and I would end up together a lot
simply because of like we were going to
the same spot after class
just walking together yeah like just
walking together during the
investigation several people were
interviewed when was the last time
you've actually physically seen her it
would be early Saturday morning we went
out to the bar and she came back to my
boyfriend's place to stay for the
evening did you see Lauren when you woke
up that morning
no it was a mystery because she's not
that kind of person that would just go
somewhere and not tell somebody where
she was do you have a key to our
apartment or did you know where she
hides the key I knew where she hides the
key and did you go inside her apartment
yes last night and did everything appear
to be undisturbed last night
there appeared to be no
forced entry with Colony well it had to
be somebody that either she knew she let
in
or had a kid in a lot of the apartment
I'm asking you for your help yes sir
this is your girlfriend I understand
because we can't find her there's people
telling me y'all
this relationship is on the rocks or not
a good relationship when I felt the
pressure of the commitment I just kind
of backed off but that's what we're
going to be in my life violent towards
no sir
at one point police interview another
acquaintance of Lauren gettings with me
is our next door neighbor who lives in
apartment four can I get your last name
McDaniel Stephen McDaniel they live next
to each other in the same apartment
complex they also attended the same Law
School
when was the last time you think you've
seen Lauren
it was either last week or the week
before that I was coming back from bar
prep and I was driving back and I saw
her going out to run he and Lauren were
both officers in the same social group
which was an organization through the
law school so anything that you could
tell me today or add to your statement
that could help me locate Lauren
I can't think of anything I mean we
looked around to see if there was a note
or if there was anything but
there was just nothing that we could
find to try and figure out where she was
however McDaniel soon goes from just a
potential source of information to a
person of interest he was arrested and
charged with burglary because during the
initial investigation he talked about
going into other people's apartments and
had taken some things like condoms and
that gave him a reason to hold on to him
but when authorities bring McDaniel back
in for more questioning he acts like a
completely different person I need to
know
about this girl right here you know her
yes
does she live next door to you yes
when's the last time you seen her
two or three weeks ago one word answers
dazed confused sort of flipping that
switch from being you know very wordy
very animated very upbeat in his answers
to being kind of catatonic
just tell me what happened brother
I don't know do you even care that no
one can find her yes earlier today me
and you sit here and talk normal what's
going on with you now why are you acting
like this I don't understand the kind of
blank stared very short answers didn't
really offer a lot of information on his
own
I was talking to people that he works
with and everything they talk about how
he's very talkative didn't they say
you're so talkative buddy that you
always so friendly you stop in and say
hello and you talk why is it that
everything that we get from you yes nor
I don't know
everyone was actually very Cooperative I
think they began to zero in on Stephen
one because of the interview that was
conducted and two initially he would not
allow a search of his apartment McDaniel
is acting incredibly peculiar but is
that enough to implicate him in getting
his disappearance when we return the
probe into McDaniel intensifies when you
say I don't know it casts another clown
over you and it's raining all over how
can you remember a statute and you can't
remember what you did two days ago
thank you
[Music]
I think someone took her how do you
think somebody would take her if
somebody did take her when she was
running
it's June 2011 down in Macon Georgia
police are interviewing Stephen McDaniel
about the sudden disappearance of his
fellow law school classmate and neighbor
Lauren Giddings one particular point of
interest is how odd he's behaving in the
interrogation room versus when he
initially spoke with authorities
you're acting like you don't know what's
going on
why are you shutting down why are you
not talking to me
I don't know as investigators speak with
McDaniel they start to get a sense of
his Odd Life how can you take it back
a week just a couple
that's funny
he sort of existed on the margins or the
fringes people thought he was strange
well you just stay in the house all day
yes wait what do you do all day in the
house play video games by yourself yes
he was more of a recluse kind of a loner
quiet you told me about how you got to
look at porn on the internet
you expressed to me that you're a virgin
correct yes what happened alone
yeah you like her don't you she's my
friend did you ever think about having
sex with her no there is reporting that
he had actually asked her out and she
was trying to be kind and just kind of
said you know I just want to be friends
you mean to tell me you look at porn on
the internet
and get off to that but you never looked
at her and said man I wonder would it be
like to have sex with her no
but let's shift away from McDaniel
investigators eventually find something
that changes the course of this whole
case and what they find is right outside
the apartment complex myself and some of
the other investigators kept noticing
just kind of a foul odor one of our
investigators open the trash can of
course it really got strong they felt
the bag down in the trash can that's
when he discovered what was a human
torso
we responded to a missing person call
that was turned over to detectives they
discovered a dead body the body was
dismembered
we got the DNA results back it wasn't
missing person my first thought was
that's somebody's daughter
that is no longer with us and it kind of
breaks your heart to realize that
detectives confront McDaniel about the
Macabre Discovery you know there was a
body found in the trash can next to the
apartments
yes who
do something somebody throw them in a
trash can
I don't know this is probably a
community dumpster and it's probably
taken out once or twice a week and I
think maybe the person ran out of time
put this in that trash and figured it
would be taken out before anyone would
notice who do you think it points to
the complete straight is going to come
to her apartment
killer
you're not going to take time
to dismember and throwing trash can a
specific crime at a specific location is
it possible that Stephen McDaniel is the
one who killed Lauren Giddings time to
take a closer look at this suspect
when's the last time you've been to
Kroger in Bakersfield
I don't remember
when's the last time were you at Walmart
I don't remember it's been a long time
can you even give me that much no
he was not forthcoming with trying to
help so sometimes you then want to focus
on those that that are not uh
forthcoming an Authority's focus on his
apartment we found several weapons to be
uh bladed weapons Firearms at Stephen
McDaniel's apartment how many guns did
you have in your apartment three then
you had that samurai sword yes did you
have any other knives in the house
yes
it also found some child pornography on
one of the jump drives it was probably
one of the hardest things to see in my
law enforcement career what do you need
all these weapons for
I have why there's a reason why
were you molested as a child no when we
returned detectives crank up the heat on
McDaniel I don't know yes you do know
and everybody making those she knows
because you got your sorry ass on the
news and told everybody
[Music]
why would you not be honest with me I am
being honest Stephen it just doesn't
feel like it buddy
this is Stephen McDaniel a 26 year old
law school graduate who investigators
believe may be behind the death of 27
year old Lauren Giddings McDaniel's
classmate and neighbor after finding
Giddings torso in the dumpster outside
her apartment building authorities are
trying to get any answers out of
McDaniel but they aren't making much
progress what do I need to tell her fam
I don't know that's what you want me to
tell her mother and her father
that you don't know
I don't know
and suspicious circumstantial evidence
begins to build around him you smell
like you've been cleaning up like you've
been using cleaner to clean up
you've been using some kind of cleaner
to clean up your apartment haven't you
no he did have a scratch on his chest
right below his sternum that night that
he told me was a spider bite well it
didn't look like a spider bite to me
with law enforcement not getting very
far with McDaniel that's when they
decide to turn things up not that you're
sorry that she's missing I thought
you've been trying to help me all day
find her but you just wanted me to tell
her I don't know
I don't know are you a sorry piece that
you want me to tell her that there was
one thing in particular that McDaniel
did early on when Lauren disappeared
that really struck a nerve with
investigators you got your ass on that
news
stood out there
and gave a media report that her mother
saw about her missing daughter
and you want me to sit there and tell
them that you don't know this was a
crime scene that the media really
descended on and so there were a lot of
news stations news channels there
interviewed people and they came across
Stephen McDaniel you're all over the
news
you sure stood out there and ran your
mouth to the news media
but now you're going to get out here and
you don't know
you know
it's just a sorry piece
that don't give them
right
yeah his interrogation didn't really
have much of a good cop bad cop
situation
um they came in hot they came in pretty
strong for him where's that little girl
Stephen
well Stephen you know where
I don't know Steve
you're gonna look at this right here at
this little girl right here
and you're gonna say you don't know I
know you know
I don't they made it very clear that he
was their suspect and they weren't here
to kind of approach any relationship
with him he went into her apartment
Stephen
and you hurt that girl no I didn't
you did Buddy why won't you tell me
Stephen
I didn't do it
[Music]
I'm gonna take this with me you don't
deserve to look at it
I appreciate all your cooperation
tonight okay okay
detectives believe McDaniel killed
Giddings but he's not giving it at all
he may be acting strange but do
authorities have enough to prove he
committed a murder
up next the incredible revelations in
the Stephen McDaniel case luminol was
sprayed on the walls and in the bathtub
of all the apartments in Lauren's
bathroom it was everywhere
foreign
[Music]
too much evidence too much evidence
you're not gonna win
2011 Macon Georgia investigators set
their sights on a man named Stephen
McDaniel who they suspect killed and
dismembered his law school classmate and
neighbor Lauren Giddings her torso found
in a dumpster outside her apartment as
they questioned him in a bizarre series
of interviews they do a deep dive into
his past one of the things that Mr
McDaniel was always wanting to talk to
people about was committing the perfect
murder he would ask that question to
people and then he would stop him and
tell him say no you're wrong let me tell
you why and then he would go into his
idea of a perfect murder you know what
he said
so these are crazy
that's your old family calling you crazy
and that's when the evidence Stacks up
against the suspected killer the gbi had
found a video that he had taken of
surveilling her apartment looking in the
window Jerry rig a camera on a pole and
you know record
he was stalking her we know that he
probably had some kind of an obsession
with her you used to watch her come in
and out of her apartment didn't you
no
didn't you just tell me that y'all were
friends yes
but you don't you didn't pay attention
when she came in and out no
Stephen you're alive
now you're lying we found a pair of her
uh underwear and his Palmer that did
have DNA on it that was her DNA
today you told an investigator
that you were worried
about us possibly finding blood in your
apartment now why would you be worried
about that
we all looked in Lauren's apartment did
you see blood no
when you spray this chemical if there's
any trace of blood he picks up on it
gives a globe her apartment in the
bathroom got lit up like a Christmas
tree you could see some marks on the tub
itself that were cuts into the little
striations into the enamel it gave you a
good indication that that's probably
where she was dismembered
you know that blood was there and that's
why you're worried about it no
a hacksaw was found in the maintenance
shed which was locked off with a key
that we later found in Stephen
McDaniel's apartment that hacksaw that
we found did have Lauren's DNA Blood and
Tissue on that we also found
packaging where it was bought and we
found receipts where it was bought from
Walmart it was the same package in
Stephen McDaniel's apartment
we know what you did too I didn't do
anything
that's what you say
what are we no different so either way
there'll be no more video games this is
the end I didn't do anything we know you
killed her
we know you put a rod in the trash can
so you can sit there with that dumb look
on your face
but it's over
Stephen McDaniel is officially charged
with the murder of Lauren gettings Hey
Stephen how are you buddy all right
let's ask a few more questions I had
nothing to say about my journey
you don't want to hear what we have
all right
I want my attorney but McDaniel's
criminal case didn't last long he ended
up pleading guilty to murdering Lauren
Giddings in my opinion I think what led
to that was the video itself
his defense team once they saw and knew
about the video they felt that that was
maybe in Mr McDaniel's best interest to
make a plea on the case
McDaniel also wrote out a detailed
confession explaining how he snuck into
Lauren's apartment in the early morning
hours of June 26 2011. watched her as
she slept and when she awoke he
strangled her to death and then
proceeded to dismember her later that
day she did admit to cutting off her
fingers and flushing them down the
toilet because she had scratched him
that night he said the rest of her body
parts he had thrown in trash dumpsters
around that area I think he tried to
make it look like he gave her a fighting
chance he was able to get on top of her
and choke her for 15 minutes I don't see
him having the physical strength to do
anything for 15 minutes I think he was
trying to make himself look stronger
than he was Stephen McDaniel was
sentenced to life in prison with the
possibility of Parole in 2041. I'm just
glad that we were able to
solve the case able to bring some
closure and some gestures to Lauren and
her family and put Mr McDaniel
where he needs to be so that he can't
harm anyone else
thought you were smarter than everybody
always leaves something a crime scene
truly this is a disturbing case and it
is so hard to think about what happened
to Lauren Giddings
as for Stephen McDaniel he spent the
last several years fighting to throw out
his guilty plea and conviction arguing
that he had bad lawyers and prosecutors
used improper evidence
but at the time of this recording Court
after court has rejected his Appeals
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime thanks so much for joining us and
until next time stay safe
[Music]
thank you
foreign